bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un auteur qui
a fait couler beaucoup d'encre continue
à faire couler beaucoup d'encre et dont
on peut dire au minimum que ses thèses
sont loin de faire l'unanimité
cet auteur c'est sigmund freud
psychanalyste et neurologues autrichien
de la fin du 19e et du début du 20e
siècle
freud est considéré comme le fondateur
de cette nouvelle discipline qui est la
psychanalyse à la fin du 19e siècle
et je précise d'emblée que la
psychanalyse n'est pas considérée
aujourd'hui comme une discipline
scientifique la psychanalyse n'est pas
une science elle ne possède pas le même
statut que la psychologie qui elle est
considérée comme une science est donc
tout ce que je veux dire à propos de la
théorie freudienne n'a aucune prétention
à la validité scientifique l'intérêt de
la proche freudienne n'est donc pas
scientifique mais plutôt philosophique à
savoir qu'elle permet de donner des
éléments d'éclairage des éléments de
compréhension sur la nature de l'esprit
humain
la nature du psychisme humain et le fait
que l'esprit humain soit en grande
partie mystérieuse insaisissable pour ne
pas dire qu'il nous échappe
la révolution freudienne a consisté à
dire que contrairement à ce que l'on
pensait l'homme ne se connaît pas
contrairement à notre intuition
contrairement à notre impression
immédiate
nous ne savons pas ce qui se passe dans
notre esprit nous ne savons pas ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de nous c'est à
dire en deçà du conscient en deçà de ce
qui apparaît de ce qui se manifeste
explicitement à notre conscience
ainsi si on veut comprendre les
principes et les objectifs de la
psychanalyse il faut aussitôt introduire
le concept clé de la psychanalyse qui
est le concept d'inconscient il n'y a
pas de psychanalyse sans le concept
d'inconscient et cette notion
d'inconscient va constituer une
véritable révolution épistémologique
dans la proche et la compréhension de la
psyché humaine
alors je viens d'employer le mot psyché
suquet en grec qui signifiait l'âme mais
qu'on traduit à partir du 19ème siècle
par le
esprit nos critères allemands la
psychanalyse c'est l'analyse de la
psyché l'analyse de l'âme
l'analyse de l'esprit humain et la
psychanalyse suppose donc que la plus
grande partie de l'esprit humain nous
est inconnue voir nous est inaccessible
et cette partie inaccessible du
psychisme humain freux de l'appel
l'inconscient alors qu'est-ce que
l'inconscient bien pour répondre à cette
question il faut d'abord dire ce que
n'est pas à l'inconscient donc
l'inconscient ce n'est pas
l'inconscience la conscience qui serait
le contraire de la conscience savait par
exemple que lorsque quelqu'un perd
connaissance
on dit qu'il est inconscient inconscient
signifie si qui n'a plus de contacts
sensorielle avec le monde on est
inconscient quand on n'est plus capable
de ressentir ou d'expérimenter avec nos
sens le monde extérieur est ce que c'est
ça l'inconscient freudien
non pas du tout c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus profond et de beaucoup
plus puissant en réalité je précise
rapidement que l'inconscient freudien ne
correspond pas non plus à ce qu'on
appelle habituellement les automatismes
c'est à dire et gestes mécaniques dans
lesquels nous n'avons pas la mémoire de
ce que nous avons fait ou de ce que nous
sommes en train de faire vous faites un
trajet en voiture vous montez les
escaliers où vous allez chercher à boire
dans le frigidaire et quelques minutes
après vous n'avez pas le souvenir de ce
que vous avez fait pas le souvenir des
endroits que vous avez traversé en
voiture ou des escaliers vous avez
grimper vous n'avez pas le souvenir
c'est à dire vous n'avez pas la
conscience de ce que vous avez fait est
ce que ça veut dire que ce que vous avez
fait est inconscient au sens freudien du
terme
non on est dans le cas ici de
l'automatisme on est tout simplement
dans le cas d'une absence d'attention
l'absence d'attention à ce que l'on fait
qui produit une absence de rétention
l'absence du souvenir de ce qu'on a fait
donc là encore on fera très attention
hein pas confondre l'inconscient
freudien avec cet inconscient au sens
courant du terme qui désigne l'absence
de souvenirs l'absence de mémorisation
de ce que l'on fait donc maintenant
qu'on a dit ce que n'était pas
inconscient
on va pouvoir dire ce qu'il est la cause
c'est une zone de l'esprit zone de la
psyché qui n'apparaît pas directement à
la conscience donc qui ne se manifestent
pas à nous qui nous échappe mais qui
agit en nous et qui agit en nous avec
une extraordinaire puissance la
conscience manifeste dans nos
comportements dans nos pensées dans nos
désirs et si on devait quantifier
l'influencé de l'inconscience sur notre
vie psychique mais on pourrait dire que
90% de notre vie psychique est régi
selon freud e par notre inconscient
freud a cette phrase qui reste est
célèbre il dit le moins n'est pas le
mettre dans sa propre maison
le mois n'est pas le mettre dans sa
propre maison ça signifie que la
conscience n'est pas l'instance
gouvernante de notre esprit la
conscience n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
de notre vie psychique
en réalité la grande majorité de notre
vie psychique et régis est déterminé par
notre inconscient donc ici on peut se
représenter l'image habituelle de
l'iceberg dont la pointe émergée
représenterait la conscience et la
partie immergée représenterait
l'inconscient et d'ailleurs c'est une
image intéressante parce qu'elle permet
de comprendre la continuité entre
l'inconscient et la conscience c'est
d'ailleurs l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de
séparation absolue et que la conscience
dépens de l'inconscient la conscience
est tout entière déterminé par
l'inconscient voilà pourquoi on peut
dire que d'un point de vue freudien nous
sommes gouvernés par notre inconscient
et ça c'est très important de le
comprendre parce que pour freud c'est
lorsqu'on comprend et qu'on admet que
notre vie psychique est gouvernée par
notre inconscient que l'on peut
commencer à s'en libérer que l'on peut
commencer à s'en affranchir
un petit peu à la manière de spinoza qui
disait que prendre conscience du fait
que nous sommes déterminés c'est déjà
s'affranchir du déterminisme prendre
conscience que nous sommes gouvernés par
notre inconscient c'est prendre
conscience que la vie de l'esprit ne
saurait se réduire à ce que nous en
connaissons la vie l'esprit ne saurait
se réduire à ce que l'esprit laisse
entrevoir de lui-même à ce que l'esprit
accepte de manifester vous allez voir
qu'à un certain nombre de phénomènes
psychiques vont vous
retrouvez leurs explications ou en tout
cas une partie de leur explication dans
cette activité de l'inconscient alors
avant d'aller plus loin
on va faire un petit retour en arrière
dans l'histoire pour se demander si la
notion d'inconscient a existé avant
freud a existé avant le 19e siècle alors
dans l'antiquité
platon a élaboré une théorie de l'âme
une cartographie de l'âme donc de ce que
nous appellerions aujourd'hui l'esprit
et se trouve que pour platon il y a dans
l'âme humaine quelque chose qui
relèverait de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'inconscient en effet pour
platon tout être humain possède en lui
la connaissance tout être humain possède
en lui le savoir mais cette connaissance
ne lui est pas consciente
cette connaissance ne lui est pas
explicitement donné donc pour platon
l'homme possède un savoir inconscient au
sens d'un savoir n'ont manifesté et le
travail du philosophe consiste
précisément à faire émerger la
connaissance au niveau conscient c'est
ce qu'on appelle la théorie de la
réminiscence et qui consiste à dire que
la connaissance est en nous et que par
un travail de raisonnement par le
travail de la confrontation des idées on
peut faire émerger la connaissance au
niveau conscient on peut faire en sorte
que ce savoir inconsciente deviennent
conscients et c'est vraiment proprement
la tâche du philosophe que de faire
émerger ce savoir au niveau conscient ce
que socrate appelé la maïeutique c'est à
dire l'art de faire accoucher les
esprits et cette métaphore de
l'accouchement est intéressante parce
que précisément
lorsqu'une femme accouche elle accouche
d'un être qui est en elle la couche d'un
être qui existent mais tin est pas
encore là devant elle
ce n'est pas encore extérioriser le
savoir inconscient doit donc
s'extérioriser et s'extériorise par le
travail de réflexion par le travail
d'investigation philosophique c'est
dialectique socratique qui permettent de
faire sortir le savoir et de le poser
hors de nous donc chez platon on a bien
quelque chose qui pourrait s'apparenter
à une forme d'inconscience mais on est
encore très très loin de l'inconscient
au sens freudien
on est encore très loin de cette idée
d'une instance ce psychique qui
gouvernerait entièrement la vie de
l'esprit et surtout on va le voir par la
suite on n'a pas du tout cette idée de
l'inconscient comme d'une force
dynamique
qui va s'exprimer qui va se traduire
dans l'apparition de certains symptômes
et vous allez voir à quel point la
question du symptôme est très importante
chez freud alors jusqu'au 16e siècle la
notion d'inconscient a été totalement
mise de côté
il n'existe pas de concept qui fasse
penser de près ou de loin à ce que freud
appelle inconscient à tel point que au
xviie siècle avec des cartes la vie
psychique ou la vie spirituelle se
résume toute entière à la conscience se
résume toute entière à la pensée
manifeste la pensée manifeste étant
celle qui apparaît à la conscience là où
l'inconscient chez freud ne se laissent
pas entrevoir par la conscience vous
vous souvenez que pour des cartes ce qui
définit l'être humain c'est avant tout
sa pensée des carpes dit nos sens
n'étant pas fiable nos sens et en ont
trop peur la seule chose dont on puisse
être absolument certain car c'est le
fait que l'on pense je peux douter de ce
que je vois je peux douter de ce que
j'entends je peux douter de ce que je
sens mais je ne peux pas douter du fait
que je pense je ne peux pas douter du
fait que une idée traversé mon esprit je
ne peux pas en douter je peux avoir
l'illusion de la sensation l'illusion de
la perception mais je ne peux pas avoir
l'illusion de la pensée parce qu'une
pensée illusoire reste une pensée
lorsque je rêve
ce que je vis n'est pas réel mais le
fait que je rêve est bien une réalité
donc pour des cartes il y à la
présupposition que rien n'existe en
dehors de la conscience il ya l'idée que
le moi c'est la conscience l'homme se
définit par la pensée la pensée est un
phénomène conscient donc l'homme se
définit par sa conscience un peu après
des cartes nous avons le philosophe
leibniz leibniz dont on a déjà parlé
on en a parlé sur la question du mal
mais hélas mythe s'est aussi interrogé
sur une autre question qui est la
question des micros perception qu'il
appelait les petites perception confuse
et qu'il a pour le coup constitue une
première tentative d'explorer cette idée
d'inconscient ou en tout cas cette idée
de phénomènes inconscient et pour vous
l'expliquer je vais vous donner des
exemples extrêmement concret
on va prendre l'exemple que vous
connaissez tous des images subliminales
qu'est ce qu'une image subliminale c'est
une image qui est insérée dans un film
dans un court métrage dans une vidéo peu
importe
et cette image vous n'aurez pas
l'impression de l'avoir vous n'aurez pas
la conscience de la voir mais vous la
verrez quand même vous la verrez à un
niveau infra conscient un niveau subi
conscient ça veut dire que votre oeil va
percevoir l'image subliminale
mais cette image ne va pas laisser de
trace sur votre conscience
elle va pour ainsi dire passé inaperçu
une image subliminale c'est une image
qui n'imprime pas son visage sur votre
rétine
c'est une image qui ne persiste pas sur
le plan sensorielles en tout cas qu'il
ne persiste pas suffisamment pour que
vous puissiez en percevoir la trace
c'est pour ça que certains disent de
manière un petit peu maladroite que
l'image subliminale n'est pas perçu par
l'oeil mais par le cerveau en réalité il
faut bien que l'image soit perçu par
l'oeil pour être perçue par le cerveau
mais l'absence de persistance rétinienne
fait que vous n'aurez pas l'impression
d'avoir vu cette image
alors évidemment on peut contester cette
idée en disant que la conscience n'est
pas la perception
ce sont deux choses différentes et on
aura raison de faire cette remarque mais
est ce que dit la bible c'est un peu
plus subtil c'est simplement de dire que
entre ce qui n'est pas perçue par la
conscience et ce qui est perçu par la
conscience il y à un continuum qui fait
qu'il n'ya pas de différence de nature
entre l'inconscient et le conscient mais
seulement une différence de degré pour
la limite ce tout ce qui est perçu de
manière consciente et tissus en réalité
de perception inconscience
je vais donc prendre un deuxième exemple
pour illustrer cette idée
c'est l'idée très connu des vagues qui
se forme sur l'océan lorsque vous
regardez une vague sur l'océan vous ne
voyez pas la totalité des gouttes qui
composent cette vague
vous voyez une vague autrement dit ce
que vous voyez c'est une sorte de
synthèse de toutes les petites
perception de tous les petits éléments
qui constituent cette vague
vous ne voyez pas l'intégralité des
micros perception qui donne lieu à la
perception de la vague
vous voyez la vague donc vous voyez le
résultat
synthétiser de l'ensemble des micros
bercy
voilà ce qu'il en est des micros
perception chez la nit mais là encore
vous voyez qu'on n'est pas dans une
approche de l'inconscient au sens
freudien du terme
on n'est pas dans l'idée que
l'inconscient serait une zone de
l'appareil psychique une zone de la vie
spirituelle la conscience correspond ici
un phénomène lié à la perception à la
micro perception c'est à dire à la
perception qu'ils ne se manifestent pas
à la conscience donc c'est vraiment à
partir du 19ème siècle avec freud qu'on
va avoir une théorie de l'inconscient
théorie de l'inconscient au niveau
psychique puisque pour freud
l'inconscient
c'est une zone de l'esprit c'est une
instance de l'appareil psychique est ce
que nous dit que l'inconscient c'est ce
qui est constitué des pensées et des
désirs refoulés
voilà la première notion qui va nous
permettre de comprendre ce qu'est
l'inconscient la notion de refoulement
alors qu'est ce que c'est que le
refoulement au sens littéral c'est le
rejet c'est la mise au ban c'est
l'expulsion l'inconscient c'est donc ce
qui est constitué de tout ce que l'on
expulse de tout ce que l'on rejette en
dehors de notre conscience
voilà pourquoi est on le verra tout à
l'heure ce qui se situe dans
l'inconscient est généralement
considérée par l'être humain comme
honteux quelque chose qu'on n'assume pas
qu'on n'assume pas et donc qu'on ne veut
pas dévoiler ou qu'on ne veut même pas
connaître parfois l'inconscience est ce
que notre respect considère comme ne
devant pas être dévoilés ne devant pas
être manifester comme n'ayant pas sa
place dans la vie consciente
c'est sale inconscient c'est ce qui n'a
pas sa place dans la vie consciente
alors pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas sa
place et bien tout simplement parce que
ça contredit ce que les normes ce que
les règles ce que les lois de notre
société autorise donc d'une certaine
manière ce qui se situe dans
l'inconscient
c'est ce qui a été censuré c'est ce qui
a été interdite rejeter ni à l'index
c'est un peu l'équivalent de l'enfer
dans les bibliothèques
vous le savez sans doute l'enfer c'était
la partie d'une bibliothèque dont les
livres étaient interdits au public
il est intéressant qu'il y ait cette
heure cette connotation diabolique cette
connotation mal
parce que dans la religion chrétienne
bien entendu l'enfer c'est le mal
c'est là où termine ce qu'ils ont vécu
dans le péché qui ont vécu dans le vi
qui ont vécu dans le crime
autrement dit qui ont vécu dans tout ce
qui est interdit
tout ce qui est interdit par la morale
mais c'est exactement ça l'inconscient
la conscience et l'enfer de notre esprit
et ce n'est pas un hasard si dans la
plupart des mythologies l'enfer où les
enfers sont généralement situés sous la
terre c'est à dire au niveau le plus bas
le plus bas étant symboliquement
associés à ce qui est indigne à skis et
ville à ce qui doit être caché là où le
ciel du paradis correspond au contraire
à la noblesse à la grandeur à la pureté
donc l'inconscient
c'est la zone de l'appareil psychique
qui contient nos désirs et nos pensées
refoulées refouler car incompatible avec
les exigences de la vie sociale
parce que dans toute vie sociale il y a
des exigences il ya des impératifs
il y à des interdits il ya des choses
qui ne se font pas voilà pourquoi on ne
peut pas comprendre la nature de
l'inconscient si on ne comprend pas que
l'inconscient est toujours le produit de
la vie dans la civilisation il y à un
inconscient parce qu'il y a civilisation
parce qu'il y a coexistence sociale
entre des individus qui doivent réprimer
leurs pulsions réprimer leurs désirs
pour pouvoir coexister
le principe de la vie sociale c'est le
principe de la coexistence de la
cohabitation
c'est donc le principe du sacrifice sur
soi même ne pas se comporter en société
comment se comporteraient si on était
tout seul ou comment se comporteraient
si on vivait dans la forêt on est obligé
de poser des limites à notre
comportement de poser des barrières à
nos usages on peut pas faire comme si
l'autre n'existait pas voilà pourquoi
dans toute société il existe des lois il
existe des normes des règles sans
lesquels nous vivrions tout simplement
comme des animaux autrement dit sans
lesquels toute vie sociale serait
impossible
or on l'a vu avec la vidéo sur rousseau
la vie en société repose sur un contrat
contrat social qui fait qu'on accepte de
troquer une partie de notre liberté
contre notre sécurité
et si le contrat social n'est pas
honorée si ce contrat social s'effondre
c'est le retour à l'état de nature
donc potentiellement le retour à la
guerre de tous contre tous pour offs
l'homme est fondamentalement égoïste et
violent et il se trouve que chez freud 2
on a exactement la même vision de
l'homme on exactement la même
anthropologie à savoir que ce qui anime
l'homme dans les profondeurs c'est la
pulsion c'est la pulsion qui le rend
violent agressif
la pulsion qui si elle n'est pas
canalisé peut donner lieu à la
sauvagerie et donc par extension à la
destruction de la civilisation
si nous ne réprimant pas nos pulsions
primitives s'il ne réprimant pas nos
instincts on ne pourrait pas vivre
on est donc obligé de faire cet exercice
de faire cet exercice de la répression
et du refoulement de nos instincts
animaux
on ne peut pas faire autrement imaginez
ce que ça donnerait si vous baladiez
dans la rue est à tout moment une
personne pouvait vous sautez dessus pour
satisfaire ses besoins sexuels ou pour
satisfaire ses pulsions meurtrières
tu serais très compliqué or il se trouve
que pour freud 2 c'est vraiment ça qui
nous anime profondément c'est cet
instinct c'est cette pulsion qui nous
poussent à la destruction
donc c'est parce que l'être humain est
fondamentalement destructeur
fondamentalement agressif envers ses
semblables que la société doit poser
d'énormes proposer des lois et que ces
lois vont agir comme une sorte de
barrière de barrières douanières de
filtres pour empêcher que la pulsion ne
puisse se manifester et mettre en péril
la vie en société
on retrouve ici l'idée de quant à propos
de l'un sociable sociabilité humaine
insociable sociabilité ça signifie que
l'homme est à la fois égoïste de par son
côté animal et altruiste de par son côté
humain mais l'être humain reste un
animal l'être humain conserve cette
partie instinctive cette partie
bestiales et c'est cette interdiction
d'exprimer sa partie animale qui va
créer à l'intérieur de l'être humain
un conflit un conflit psychique un
conflit qui va déboucher sur ce que
freud appelle la névrose alors je ne
veux pas rentrer dans le détail de ce
concept de névroses et simplement pour
simplifier un petit peu les choses
la névrose c'est tout simplement le
résultat d'un conflit psychique là
conflits intérieurs entre deux éléments
contradictoires entre deux exigences
incompatibles entre par exemple le désir
d'avoir un rapport sexuel et le devoir
de rester vierge entre le désir de
rouler en ferrari et de partir en
vacances aux seychelles et le devoir de
se lever tous les matins à 6 heures pour
aller bosser
la névrose c'est ce qui résulte d'un
conflit entre le désir et le devoir et
une fois qu'on a compris cette idée de
conflits intérieurs entre le désir et le
devoir un conflit qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans les tragédies grecques
chez les héros tragiques qui sont
tiraillés entre la raison et la passion
puisque la tragédie
c'est une illustration et en même temps
une catharsis c'est-à-dire un moyen
d'évacuation de ce conflit entre raison
et passion de ce conflit entre devoir et
désire le héros tragique c'est celui qui
parce que son désir est trop puissant
parce que son désir et tyrannique
cessent d'obéir à la raison cessent
d'obéir aux devoirs cessent d'obéir à la
loi avec un l majuscule équipe parce
qu'il désobéit à la loi sera puni sera
puni par le destin sera puni par les
dieux sera puni par le fantôme
c'est ça la raison d'être de la tragédie
ou en tout cas l'une de ses raisons
d'être
l'illustration et l'évacuation
cathartique du conflit entre raison et
passion chez l'homme donc pour le dire
très vite selon freud nous sommes tous
des névrosés absolument tous sans
exception alors nous sommes tous plus ou
moins parce que nous sommes plus ou
moins tiraillé par nos désirs où nous
sommes plus ou moins sous la pression du
devoir et des personnes dont le milieu
dont l'environnement dont la famille
leur accorde plus ou moins de marge de
manoeuvre leur accorde plus ou moins de
souplesse dans la satisfaction de leurs
désirs quand on grandit dans un couvent
on a des chances de finir comme emma
bovary
on a des chances de vouloir extérioriser
nos pulsions réprimées on a des chances
d'exploser
al'inverse si on évolue dans un milieu
où cette pression du devoir cette
pression de l'interdît cette pression de
la règle ne se fait pas ressentir ou se
fait moins ressentir à ce moment-là il y
a des chances pour que la névrose soit
moins forte vous souvenez ce qu'on
disait sur la politesse la politesse
c'est cet effort altruiste qui permet la
cohabitation avec l'autre si cet effort
que l'on
produit sur nous mêmes pour assurer les
conditions de la coexistence avec
l'autre c'est un effort c'est une
pression exercée sur notre désir sur
notre animalité
l'animal n'a pas besoin d'être poli
haine mal
il se sert si quelqu'un n'est pas
d'accord c'est la lutte à mort n'a pas
de l'evros les animaux à l'état sauvage
il n'y a pas de refoulement de la
pulsion donc ya pas d inconscient alors
ils trouvent que cette loi on va appeler
ça la loi avec un l majuscule et donc
quand je dirais loi je voudrais parler
de toutes les normes sociales de toutes
les conventions de toutes les règles
dans lesquels on baigne qui nous sont
transmises par l'éducation
donc cette loi elle nous est non
seulement imposé par la société imposées
par notre environnement social mais elle
finit même par nous être imposée par
nous mêmes autrement dit nous devenons
nous mêmes une autorité par laquelle on
s'interdit s'attelle choses et par
laquelle on s'autorise certaines choses
autrement dit ils existent pour freud eu
une autre zone de l'esprit qu'il appelle
le surmoi et le surmoi c'est l'instance
de la loi c'est l'instance de la norme
c'est le petit gendarmes intérieur qui
nous surveillent et qui nous empêchent
de suivre aveuglément nos pulsions on
pourrait dire que le surmoi c'est
l'instance de la bonne conscience au
sens de la conscience morale c'est le
petit ange posée sur l'épaule qui nous
dit mme tu ne devrais pas faire ça ça tu
as le droit ça tu n'as pas le droit
ça c'est bien mais ça c'est mal ces
salles sur moi j'ai pris l'image du
gendarme et je pourrais prendre celle du
juge
parce que le juge c'est celui qui
sanctionne c'est celui qui représente
l'autorité de la loi et dont le verdict
est irrévocable le juge c'est la loi et
donc nous avons tous notre petit juge
intérieur qui est le surmoi et le surmoi
c'est ce qui va vous donner un cadre de
discipline d'autodiscipline une
autodiscipline qui peut parfois être
nécessaire et bénéfique pour vous mais
c'est aussi ce qui va produire en vous
de la culpabilité la culpabilité d'avoir
mal agi
la culpabilité d'avoir fait quelque
chose que vous n'auriez pas dû faire
selon les critères dits s'impose à vous
le surmoi
c'est ce qui va produire en vous la
honte c'est tout sale sur moi le surmoi
c'est l'oeil de la conscience l'oeil
dans la tombe qui regardent qu'un dans
le poème de victor hugo
c'est à dire l'oeil de la culpabilité
l'oeil de l'intériorisation des normes
le surmoi
c'est ce qui est issu de
l'intériorisation de la loi voilà
pourquoi le surmoi n'est pas aussi
développé chez l'enfant que chez
l'adulte par exemple parce que c'est un
processus dynamique le processus
d'intériorisation de la loi et
l'intériorisation de la loi ça signifie
que ce qui au départ nous est imposée de
l'extérieur par la société par nos
parents par nos professeurs par nos
frères et soeurs fini par être intégré
en nous à tel point qu'on ne le remet
plus en cause
à tel point qu'on ne remarque même plus
que c'est quelque chose qui vient de
l'extérieur
l'intériorisation de la loi c'est
l'acceptation de la loi comme faisant
partie de nous
ça c'est très important de le comprendre
parce que sinon on va réduire la loi une
simple autorité extérieure qui
s'imposent à nous alors que non ce
serait trop simple
ce serait trop simple de dire qu'il y a
des lois qui s'impose à nous et qu'on
n'a pas le droit de faire ce qu'on veut
c'est pas ça c'est pas qu'on n'a pas
droit de faire ce qu'on veut c'est pas
qu'on n'a pas le droit de satisfaire nos
désirs c'est qu'on s'interdit nous même
de les satisfaire et l'idée que nous
serions opprimés par des règles et des
normes qui nous empêche de nous libérer
qui nous empêche de nous épanouir
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche
personne ne vous interdit de faire ce
que vous voulez dans l'immense majorité
des cas c'est vous même c'est vous même
qui vous dit c'est une mauvaise idée
je ne devrais pas ces risques c'est
dangereux c'est nous qui nous le disons
et sa fraude l'avait parfaitement
compris il avait compris qu'il était
beaucoup trop
s'il de réduire la pression sociale de
réduire la pression civilisationnel à la
seule autorité des lois qui nous
gouvernent
en réalité depuis l'enfance nous
intériorise on les lois de la société et
parfois même nous en rajoutons et nous
finissons par devenir notre propre
gendarmes
notre propre juge notre propre
surveillants et c'est ça qui crée la
névrose
c'est cette impossibilité de satisfaire
notre pôle pulsionnel qui crée de la
névrose et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
explique en grande partie qu'on puisse
voir des gens qui comme on dit
familièrement vont péter un câble ont
pété un câble parce qu'il supporte
depuis trop longtemps une pression
qu'ils se sont eux-mêmes imposées et qui
à mon sens données explose toujours est
il comme on parle du sur moi depuis tout
à l'heure
et que devient notre inconscient pendant
ce temps là bien il faut savoir déjà que
offrir deux le surmoi est lui même en
grande partie inconscient
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas
forcément conscience d'être nous même
notre propre gendarmes notre propre
surveillants et que parfois nous
agissons d'une manière qui nous semble
tout simplement normal c'est-à-dire en
conformité avec les impératifs de la
société les impératifs de la coexistence
avec autrui et donc on ne se rend même
pas compte qu'on est dans un processus
de répression de refoulement de
limitation de nos désirs et de nos
pulsions donc le surmoi est en grande
partie inconscient mais ce qu'on a
appelé l'inconscient tout à l'heure à
savoir l'ensemble des désirs et des
pensées refoulées par le surmoi cet
inconscient va se situer dans la zone
inférieure de l'appareil psychique que
freud appelle le ca ca c cédille à das s
en allemand et d'ailleurs je me souviens
que lorsque j'étais au lycée que j'ai
entendu pour la première fois prononcé
le mot ça j'ai pas compris tout de suite
ce que ça voulait dire j'ai pas compris
tout de suite pourquoi ce mot parce que
ça me paraissait être un mot ou pas du
tout conceptuel
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le ca c'est
très étrange comme expression autant le
surmoi en arriva à se faire une
représentation de ce que ça peut vouloir
dire mais autant le ca si beaucoup plus
obscures
et quelques années plus tard j'ai
compris que c'était justement ce
caractère un petit peu obscur un petit
peu confus un petit peu floue de ce
terme qui justifiait son emploi le st
c'est quelque chose qui ne se laisse pas
définir ça c'est quelque chose qui ne se
laisse pas déterminées dont on ne peut
pas délimiter les contours et bien c'est
là que se situe ce qu'on appelle les
désirs inconscients dans le ca dans ce
ca qui agissent sur la personnalité et
est en conflit permanent avec le surmoi
le ca est en conflit permanent avec le
surmoi que ça on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est la zone pulsionnel c'est le
réservoir pulsionnel le réservoir du
désir qui cherchent à s'exprimer malgré
les injonctions du surmoi malgré la
barrière douanière du surmoi le sas et
ce torrent énergétique c'est ce
déchaînement de forces qui cherchent à
s'exprimer
envers et contre tous qui cherchent à
s'exprimer au delà des règles de
bienséance et des interdictions
donc je répète que l'inconscient ne se
limite pas au sein puisque le surmoi est
lui même en partie inconscient mais en
revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
l'inconscient est en grande partie
constitué par le sang certains
commentateurs ont choisi d'illustrer le
ca par l'image de la cave la cave c'est
un endroit par du temps obscurs mid qui
peut chez les enfants inspirer la
crainte est d'ailleurs le film inspiré
du roman de stephen king ça dont
certains ma génération peut être vu la
version des années 90 il est revenu il
est revenu c'est l'histoire de ce clown
tueur qui terrorise un groupe d'enfants
et qui les met face à leurs angoisses
évidemment le fait que le roman de
stephen king et le film s'appelle ça
n'est évidemment pas un hasard puisque
c'est l'allégorie la confrontation à nos
angoisses
l'allégorie de la confrontation à
l'irrationnel et donc il se trouve que
dans le film il est revenu
vous avez ce petit enfant georgie qui
descend dans la cave de sa maison qui
tente vainement d'allumer la lumière
l'an poule ne fonctionne pas et qui
descend à toute vitesse chercher ce dont
il a besoin pour faire flotter son
bateau et on voit à quel point l'image
de la cave représente pour lui une
angoisse absolue
parce que c'est l'inconnu parce que
c'est l'imperceptible celle
insaisissable il ya le saas est un petit
peu la caf de notre esprit le saas est
l'endroit où a pas forcément envie
d'aller voir
on a peut-être peur de ce qu'on pourrait
y trouver c'est vraiment ça ça et la
seule chose
on puisse dire à propos du sein c'est
qu'il agit en nous ça agit en ou s'agit
ça veut dire que nous sommes poussés et
déterminé par cette force inconnue avec
laquelle nous sommes en lutte permanente
avec laquelle le surmoi est en conflit
constant alors là je fais un petite
parenthèse pour préciser un petit peu
cette cartographie du psychisme humain
selon freud 2 qu'il a notamment
développé en 1920 à travers sa seconde
topic
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'une topic
utopique c'est tout simplement la
représentation de quelque chose
d'abstrait sous forme de lieu sous forme
de cartes donc la carte du psychisme
humain ont pour elle a représenté par
exemple par une fusée dont laitages le
plus bas seraient le st le pôle
pulsionnel la pointe supérieure serait
le surmoi donc l'instance de la loi
l'instance normative et entre les deux
se situent à un étage intermédiaire que
freud appelle sobrement le mois le mois
c'est tout simplement
l'instance de conciliation freud eux
parlent de compromis
l'instance de compromis entre le ça et
le surmoi autrement dit le mois c'est la
partie qui doit gérer le conflit entre
le ça et le surmoi c'est le médiateur
entre le désir pulsionnel et la raison
normative c'est ça le moins donc le moi
évidemment il est affecté par ce conflit
il est touché par ce conflit et il en
subit les conséquences
c'est le mois qui doit composer avec ces
deux forces contradictoires qui
s'affrontent
voilà pourquoi le mois et soumis à la
névrose
parce que dans le même temps où il ne
peut pas se soustraire aux injonctions
du surmoi il ne peut pas non plus
ignorer son désir et sa pulsion il ne
peut pas mettre son désir en pause
il ne peut pas neutralisé paralysé le ca
le mois c'est ce qui recueille le
conflit entre le surmoi et le ca c'est
l'instance de médiation entre ces deux
pôles opposés de l'appareil psychique
donc je ne parlerai pas ici de la
première topic freudienne qui est un
petit peu différente puisque dans la
première topic freux distingue le
conscient le pré conscient et
l'inconscient
mais comme il a révisé et corriger cette
conception je préfère vous donner
directement
seconde topic qui me semble en plus
beaucoup plus facile à comprendre
donc j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises que
l'être humain était en très grande
partie déterminée par son inconscient
est d'autant plus déterminé que nous
n'avons pas accès à cette attention nous
n'avons pas accès à notre inconscient
alors nous n'y avons pas accès mais en
fait si on ya quand même accès à travers
des chemins détournés
on ya accès de manière indirecte il y a
plusieurs voies par lesquelles
l'inconscient se manifeste à la
conscience la première voie étant le
rêve le rêve selon freud eux c'est le
théâtre qui permet la mise en scène est
l'expression du désir inconscient
c'est ce qui fait que très souvent dans
vos rêves vous aurez des décors qui vous
seront familiers et très souvent le
matériau de nos rêves
il est emprunté à ce que nous avons vécu
le jour même ou la veille
il est assez fréquent que dans nos rêves
on retrouve des éléments de la journée
qu'on vient de passer au de la journée
précédente
parce que nos perceptions parce que
notre expérience c'est le matériau de
notre vie psychique mais je disais que
le rêve était le lieu d'expression du
désir inconscient mais je dois aussitôt
précisé que pour freud 2 ce n'est pas à
proprement parler nous qui rêvons en
réalité ce n'est pas nous qui rêvons
c'est notre inconscient et sa
distinction est très importante parce
que de la même façon que freud nous dit
que le mois n'est pas le mettre dans sa
propre maison
freud nous dit également que nous ne
sommes pas responsables de ce que nous
vivons dans nos rêves nos rêves
ce n'est pas nous nos rêves c'est notre
inconscient et nous ne sommes pas notre
inconscient on ne choisit pas ce qu'on
désire de manière inconsciente
nous ne sommes pas responsables de notre
inconscient l'outil freud et si nous ne
sommes pas responsables de notre
inconscient
nous ne sommes pas fautif donc nous
n'avons pas à avoir honte de nos rêves
nous n'avons pas à avoir honte de ce que
révèle notre inconscient nous n'avons
pas en avoir honte
nous n'avons pas à culpabiliser d'autant
plus que pour freud il faut distinguer
dans le rêve
ce qu'il appelle le contenu manifeste et
le contenu latent le contenu manifeste
c'est tout simplement ce qui se produit
dans votre rêve
c'est ce qui apparaîtrait 6
on pouvait transformer votre rêve en
film ça c'est le contenu manifeste c'est
ce qui se passe concrètement
explicitement dans votre rêve
par exemple vous imaginez que vous
retournez au lycée vous devez repasser
votre bac et vous entrez dans une salle
avec des personnes qui ont 20 ans de
moins que vous avec un surveillant tout
ce que vous voulez ça c'est le contenu
manifeste de votre rêve c'est la
situation concrète que vous vivez dans
votre rêve maintenant il ya le contenu
latent et le contenu latent ça signifie
ce que veut dire votre rêve
ça signifie ce qui n'apparaît pas dans
votre rêve mais se révèle à travers lui
ce que certains appelleront la
signification du rêve
c'est ça le contenu latent et pour freud
ce qui compte c'est le contenu latent
dont le contenu manifeste n'est qu'un
mode d'expression le contenu manifeste
n'est qu'un prétexte pour le contenu
latent de trouver un moyen de s'exprimer
c'est comme si votre inconscient se
déguisait de telle sorte que vous
puissiez le voir sans forcément le
reconnaître je dis sans forcément le
reconnaître parce que vous ne savez pas
forcément ce qui se cache derrière le
costume ne savait pas forcément ce qui
se cache derrière le contenu manifeste
de votre rêve
vous rêvez vous repasser votre bac ça
veut pas dire que vous avez raté votre
bac quand vous étiez jeune ça peut
simplement vouloir dire que la situation
qui consiste à repasser son bac est une
manière déguisée de vous dire quelque
chose dont le bac n'est qu'un avatar
dont le bac n'est peut-être qu'une forme
d'expression parmi d'autres c'est pas
forcément le bac qui agite votre
inconscient et ce contenu manifeste tant
qu'il n'est pas interprété tant qu'il
n'est pas éclairée par le travail d'
analyse vous ne pouvez rien en déduire
interpréter un rêve ce n'est pas prendre
le contenu manifeste de ce rêve pour le
message la signification du rêve ne se
limite pas au contenu manifeste du rêve
interpréter un rêve consiste à déduire
du contenu manifeste le contenu latent à
comprendre de quoi le contenu manifeste
et l'expression c'est ça
l'interprétation du rêve
il existe une autre manière pour
l'inconscient de s'exprimer autre que le
rêve c'est le lapsus alors le lapsus
peut être aussi bien écrit chorale et le
lapsus va consister en une erreur de
langage mais une erreur qui va être
considéré comme étant révélatrice et
vous noterez bien que le mot révélé
signifie montrer la vérité révélée s'est
ôté ce qui couvre la vérité donc le
lapsus selon freud est révélateur
révélateur de l'inconscient non pas
révélateur de vos pensées intimes mais
révélateur des pensées et des désirs qui
vous échappent dépensés dont vous n'êtes
pas responsables donc selon freud
lorsque vous commettez un lapsus lorsque
vous remplacer un mot par un autre et la
plupart du temps avec une connotation
sexuelle bien selon freud vous êtes la
victime nous est le jouet de votre
inconscient qui trouvent un moyen de
s'exprimer à travers le langage donc par
exemple imaginons que vous allez en
réunion le matin et puis en partant de
la réunion il est midi et vous dit à vos
collègues bonne soirée alors dire bonne
soirée à midi ça peut signifier que vous
êtes déjà un peu fatigué ça peut
signifier que vous vous êtes vraiment
ennuyé durant cette réunion est que
votre bonne soirée traduit le désir que
la journée soit fini ça ça peut être un
exemple de l'absence donc le lapsus
c'est tout simplement le remplacement
d'un mot par un autre qui va traduire ce
que vous pensez de manière inconsciente
ce que vous désirez de manière
inconsciente voilà pourquoi beaucoup de
lapsus sont à caractère sexuel parce que
pour freud de la pulsion qui nous
dirigent la pulsion de l'inconscience
est une pulsion d'ordre sexuel on
reproche d'ailleurs souvent affreux de
toutes interprétées sous l'angle de la
sexualité et c'est vrai d'ailleurs c'est
quelque chose qu'il assume parfaitement
parce que pour lui la pulsion sexuelle
c'est l'alpha et l'oméga de notre
animalité
on pourrait même aller jusqu'à dire que
pour freud de tout désir trouve son
origine dans la pulsion sexuelle donc
commettre un lapsus à caractère sexuel
pour freud ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire
ça n'a rien de surprenant ça n'a rien de
honteux puisque de toute façon notre vie
psychique étant entièrement gouverné par
l'inconscient ça revient à dire qu'elle
est entièrement gouverné par la pulsion
sexuelle
le dernier mode d'expression de
l'inconscient chez freud eux c'est
l'acte manqué alors l'acte manqué j'ai
l'habitude de dire que c'est un petit
peu l'équivalent du lapsus
mais avec des actes c'est par exemple le
fait que vous n'ayez pas entendu le
réveil sonne et alors même que vous
aviez rendez vous pour un très important
entretien d'embauché donc imaginons que
vous vous préparez la veille de cet
entretien toutes vos affaires sont
prêtes vous avez mis votre réveil vous
êtes couchée tôt pour être sûr de bien
entendre et quelque chose fait que vous
n'entendez pas le réveil sonner vous
n'entendez pas le réveil sonne et vous
vous levez en retard et vous vous
dépêcher pour courir à la gare et
prendre votre train pour arriver à
l'heure à l'entretien et là pas de
chance pile au moment où vous arrivez
sur le quai le train est en train de
partir vous dans cette situation vous
serez sincèrement convaincu que vous
n'avez pas eu de chance vous serez
sincèrement convaincu que vous vouliez
aller à cet entretien vous vouliez
décrocher ce boulot mais quelque chose
nous a empêchés et bien sachez freud ça
peut s'assimiler à un acte manqué c'est
à dire un message de votre inconscient
pour vous faire comprendre que vous
n'aviez pas envie d'obtenir ce boulot
que quelque chose en vous refusez ces
salles acte manqué l'acte manqué comme
le lapsus ce sont des échecs révélateur
ce sont des échecs qui traduisent la
réalité de votre désir inconscient et
d'une certaine manière c'est trois modes
de manifestations de l'inconscient ils
sont extrêmement utiles ils sont
extrêmement précieux parce qu'ils
permettent à leur échelle de libérer un
peu la pression sur l'inconscient ils
permettent à l'inconscient de s'exprimer
quand le surmoi le dos tourné
et ça c'est très important le souligner
parce que si le désir inconscient ne
trouve aucun moyen de s'exprimer à ce
moment là la névrose peut dégénérer
elle peut dégénérer en psychose elle
peut dégénérer en hystérie
elle peut dégénérer dans toutes les
formes de pathologies que freud a
identifié et qui traduisent à chaque
fois l'incapacité à supporter le conflit
entre le sens et le surmoi alors il se
trouve que freud âme à forger un concept
extrêmement intéressants dont j'ai envie
de vous parler pour terminer cette vidéo
un concept qui traduit un autre mode de
manifestation du désir inconscient
c'est le concept de sublimation alors le
mot sublimation au départ il appartient
au domaine de la physique la sublimation
c'est le passage de l'état solide à
l'état gazeux passage direct sans passer
par l'état liquide et se trouve cet
intéressant de noter que sur le plan
physique
cette transformation ce passage de
l'état solide à l'état gazeux suppose
que le corps soit animée d'une énergie
or il se trouve que le désir est une
énergie
c'est une énergie qui est à l'origine de
nos pensées de nos comportements
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'expliquer dans
d'autres vidéos le désir c'est d'abord
une force de mise en mouvement c'est la
force qui nous pousse à vouloir
rejoindre notre partie manquante
alors qu'est ce que la sublimation la
sublimation
c'est le processus de détournements et
de réorientation du désir vers un but
supérieure d'art à but considéré comme
plus élevé plus noble on pourrait dire
que la sublimation c'est
l'investissement du désir sexuel dans un
but non sexuel
c'est ça la sublimation l'investissement
du désir sexuel dans un but non sexuel
on va prendre un exemple concret on
prend l'exemple d'un homme qui éprouve
un désir sexuel et qui a la malchance
d'être célibataire donc cet homme est là
plusieurs options
la première option c'est de réfréner son
désir sexuel
c'est de le réprimer au risque de
produire une petite névroses
une autre option ça va être de se
masturber autrement dit de satisfaire
ses pulsions sexuelles de manière
immédiate mais le problème de cette
option problème entre guillemets bien
sûr c'est que son énergie sexuelle donc
sa libido va être gaspillé cette énergie
sexuelle ne va pas être investis dans
quelque chose de supérieur donc certes
ça va permettre à cet homme d'assouvir
sa pulsion de se libérer de sa pulsion
mais il n'y aura pas de finalité
supérieure à 7 assouvissement n'y aura
pas de but socialement noble dans cette
satisfaction
enfin la troisième option qui s'offre à
cet homme ça va être d'investir cette
énergie sexuelle dans un acte de
création dans un acte de production et
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler une sa
ce action immédiate du désir
satisfaction immédiate médiatisée c'est
à dire qui va passer par un
intermédiaire et l'acte de création va
constituer un intermédiaire entre le
désir et la satisfaction de ce désir
c'est l'exemple que prend freud de
l'artiste l'artiste lorsqu'il crée une
oeuvre
il a besoin d'énergie il a besoin de
libido il a besoin d'une force de
création qui va s'exprimer à travers la
réalisation d'une oeuvre
autrement dit l'artiste va détourner sa
pulsion sexuelle vers la création d'une
oeuvre socialement valorisé
donc on peut prendre l'exemple de
l'artiste non on peut aussi prendre
l'exemple du chercheur
l'intellectuel du scientifique qui lui
va convertir son énergie sexuelle en
énergie intellectuelle en force de
compréhension vous voyez à travers ces
deux exemples
l'artiste est l'intellectuel que
l'énergie sexuelle peut être convertie
vers une autre finalité vers une
finalité non sexuel dernier finalité
abstraite symbolique culturelle une
finalité qui en apparence n'a absolument
rien de sexuel et je disais tout à
l'heure que pour freud tout et sexuelle
c'est exactement ce que nous montre la
sublimation
parce que même si le désir sassou vie
sous une forme non sexuel
il n'empêche que ce désir il est de
nature sexuelle la pulsion créatrice
c'est une pulsion d'origine sexuelle
donc au lieu de gaspiller son désir ou
de l'exprimer de manière chaotique
l'individu va pouvoir transformer et
réorienter sa pulsion vers la création
d'une oeuvre qui aura de la valeur
j'ai pris l'exemple de l'artiste j'ai
pris l'exemple de l'intellectuel on
pourrait tout aussi bien prendre
l'exemple du sportif l'exemple de
l'athlète qui dans le cadre d'une
performance physique ou qui dans le
cadre d'une compétition sportive va
devoir accumulé suffisamment d'énergie
va devoir accumulé suffisamment de
libido pour pouvoir réaliser sa
performance
toute personne qui a fait des combats de
boxe c'est que l'abstinence est de mise
plusieurs semaines avant le combat le
boxeur ne peut pas se permettre de
dilapider toute son énergie avant un
combat
donc cette libido cette agressivité
pulsionnel et sexuelle le boxeur va
l'utiliser à son profit il va l'utiliser
comme force de combat
il va l'utiliser comme énergie
créatrice je disais que le désir du ca
l'énergie sexuelle du ca freud l'appeler
la libido
il se trouve que le mot libido n'est pas
une invention moderne c'est un mot latin
qu'on retrouve déjà chez saint-augustin
au cinquième siècle après jésus-christ
et d'ailleurs c'est amusant de constater
que déjà à cette époque saint-augustin
distinguer trois types de libido trois
types de libido c'est à dire trois types
d'énergie sexuelle qui pouvait avoir des
destinations différentes
alors pour que ce soit très concret je
vais tout de suite vous les citer la
première libido chez saint-augustin
c'est la libido sciendi autrement dit
c'est l'énergie proprement sexuelle
proprement sensuel c'est l'énergie qui
correspond au désir proprement
corporelle
donc on pourrait dire que la libido sant
yann fichet saint-augustin c'est la
pulsion sexuelle brut c'est la pulsion
sexuelle qui n'est pas détourné de sa
destination
c'est celle qui ne cherchent pas à
s'auto dépassé dans la création d'une
oeuvre supérieur la deuxième libido
c'est la libido dominant dit qu'on
traduit généralement par l'orgueil et ça
ça correspond chez saint-augustin au
désir de dominer l'autre on peut
retrouver notamment chez les guerriers
donc le guerrier c'est celui qui va
détourner son énergie sexuelle vers le
combat contre l'ennemi et ça rejoint
vous le remarquez ce que je disais tout
à l'heure sur le boxeur qui va utiliser
son énergie sexuelle pour gagner son
combat
le troisième type de libido c'est la
libido sciendi qui correspond au désir
de connaissance et ça c'est exactement
ce que frau ne décrit à travers le
processus de la sublimation
c'est à dire le détournement de la
pulsion sexuelle va la création de
quelque chose d'abstrait et
l'abstraction ça correspond
symboliquement à l'élévation du désir à
une réalité
jugé plus noble ces trois libido qu'on
trouve chez saint-augustin ont été
reprises par pascal au xviie siècle à
travers ce qu'il appelait les trois
concupiscence c'est à dire les trois
désirs humains qui sont la marque du
péché originel
donc là on s'aventure sur un terrain un
peu plus religieux mais peu importe
parce que ce qui compte c'est de
comprendre ce processus ce processus de
transformation du désir sexuel en
quelque chose de non sexuel et pour
pascal la libye
aussi indique saint-augustin c'est à
dire le désir de connaissance c'est tout
simplement la curiosité curiosité qui a
conduit adam et eve à goûter le fruit
défendu et donc à être expulsés du
jardin d'éden
pour pascal la libido sciendi ne se
différencie pas d autres libido des
autres concupiscence elles ne sont
différencie pas parce qu'elle a la même
origine et pour pascal c'est justement
parce que nous sommes des êtres
imparfaits d être corrompu et frappée du
sceau du péché que nous sommes pour
ainsi dire condamnés à la misère une
sommes incapables de nous élever à la
sphère du divin donc chez pascal comme
chez saint-augustin il y à l'idée que
l'être humain est fondamentalement
déterminé par son désir par sa libido
par sa pulsion sexuelle et même avant
saint-augustin chez platon par exemple
on trouve déjà cette idée cette idée du
désir qui nous anime
platon avait une conception de l'âme
humaine une conception de la psyché qui
était elle aussi divisée en trois
parties la partie la plus inférieur
c'est ce qu'il appelait les pitous bien
qui correspond au désir du corps aux
désirs matériels aux désirs reproductif
c'est à dire à la libido s'interdit de
saint-augustin et qui correspond à
l'expression brute du désir sexuel
la deuxième partie de l'âme chez platon
la partie intermédiaire c'est ce qu'il
appelait le tum hausse et le tue moss
c'est la colère c'est la partie
irascible
c'est l'ardeur l'ardeur du guerrier là
encore qui va lui donner du courage par
le désir de vaincre
donc là encore on a cette idée de
transformation de réorientation du désir
vers un but jugée supérieure et enfin la
troisième partie de l'âme la partie
supérieure c'est ce que platon appelle
le logos et qui correspond à la partie
rationnelle à la partie de l'esprit qui
est dirigé vers la connaissance et ça ça
correspond à la sublimation freudienne
c'est à dire à la transformation du
désir sexuel en énergie de connaissances
dont il est exact de dire que pour freud
tout et sexuelle mais il faut bien
comprendre
en quel sens tout et sexuelle je ne dis
pas que tout et sexuelles au sens où
notre seul objectif ce serait d'avoir
des rapports sexuels freux nous dit que
tout et sexuelles au sens où tout ce qui
anime nos comportements et d'origine
sexuelle mais d'origine sexuelle ne veut
pas dire à destination sexuelle
d'origine sexuelle ne veut pas dire que
tous nos désirs
saint carné se concrétiser dans l'acte
sexuel et ça c'est très important de
comprendre c'est très important de le
comprendre parce que avec le concept de
sublimation freud nous montre que nous
avons une possibilité de maîtriser notre
désir c'est là que réside notre part de
liberté
il reste une part de liberté à l'homme
cette part de liberté elle consiste à
choisir la manière dont on veut que le
désire s'exprimer
elle consiste à décider de la
destination que l'on va donner à la
pulsion sexuelle
ce qu'on appelle par exemple les pistes
hémophilie c'est-à-dire étymologiquement
l'amour de la connaissance les pistes
hémophilie c'est un détournement la
pulsion sexuelle
est ce que pour autant on va mettre sur
le même plan le fait d'être un obsédé
sexuel et le fait d'être un amoureux de
la connaissance est ce qu'on va mettre
sur le même plan la masturbation
compulsive et la tentative de comprendre
le monde
alors certes pour freud de ces deux
démarches ont exactement la même
provenance est ce que ça veut dire pour
autant qu'elles ont la même valeur
non elles n'ont pas la même valeur parce
que dans un cas le cas de la
satisfaction immédiate
c'est le désir qui nous manipulent
tandis qu'avec la sublimation
c'est nous qui utilisons le désir pour
en faire quelque chose de supérieur à ce
moment là le désir n'est plus une simple
force qui nous détermine une force dont
nous serions les esclaves le désir
devient l'instrument de notre
accomplissement le désir devient
l'énergie par laquelle nous accédons à
quelque chose de supérieur et dans ce
cas larmes
même si nous sommes entièrement
déterminé par notre inconscient même si
nous sommes entièrement conditionné par
notre désir inconscient il nous reste
cependant une marge de manoeuvre nous
reste cependant cette part de liberté
par laquelle nous devenons quelque chose
de plus qu'un simple désir quelque chose
de plus qu'une simple pulsions nous
devenons des êtres humains capables de
créer capable de transformer le monde
capable de sublimer le monde
je vous remercie
[Musique]
oui et
on